there's not much to go on but that's
where you come in
dexter morgan forensics expert
he's drifting further toward kurt
he was probably a murderer yeah and so
are you wow that's
fair hey guys pete here today i'm going
to look at dexter new blood episode 7 by
looking at the description the teaser
trailer and the promotional photos that
showtime released i'll be breaking the
teaser down then i'll speculate on what
this all might mean for skin of her
teeth and then i'll discuss some of the
popular theories that are kicking around
after episode 6. if any of that sounds
like spoilers to you then this is your
chance to leave and with that out of the
way let's get into it
the description for episode 7 reads
dexter is worried that a serial killer
may have set its sights on someone he
cares deeply about so he turns from
predator to protector a role he's not
comfortable playing meanwhile angela
arrests someone from iron lake who may
be the culprit of a cold case that is
near and dear to her heart dexter and
harrison run into some more bumps in the
road in their relationship leading
harrison to a very dangerous person as
his father figure and i'll come back
around to that because most of it is
touched on in this teaser that opens
with angela saying there's not much to
go on but that's where you come in
dexter morgan forensics expert they're
in the cave where she found iris it
looks like it's still the same night and
i suppose she's doing just what she said
she needs help she wants to find out if
there's anything here that she can go on
we hear deb say that he's drifting
further towards kurt and there's a funny
back and forth between them where she
points out that both of the people who
are father figures in his life right now
are killers it looks like harrison and
dexter are still distant after the
therapy session and he fears that this
is driving him towards his relationship
with kurt it looks as though he left
another full plate of food behind and i
love how jack alcott is doing his best
michael c hall impression in this shot
right here there's a couple of shots of
dexter sneaking into what i presume is
kurt's office considering matt's high
school graduation picture is in a frame
on the desk then the two men are sitting
across from each other in a booth at
kurt's truck stop he says there was a
time when i thought you and i would be
friends out loud and dexter thinks
except you kill innocent women and i
kill guys like you while that
conversation is going on angela and dex
arrive at kurt's cabin in her police car
no real indication here how they got
there but we do see her shoot the lock
on the storm door so they can access the
basement and they do go in this is a
little odd i think it's just her and her
estranged ex-forensic specialist
boyfriend shooting the lock seems like a
really informal way of entering as part
of an official investigation i guess
we'll have to wait and see what's going
on there then there's a sequence of kurt
getting booked at the station they're
taking his photo and his prints and we
see them bag his personal belongings it
looks like bad news for kurt and dexter
too since the trailer ends with him
thinking about how much he'd like to get
him on his table problem solved then no
more iron lake serial killer right well
other than having a weird room that
clearly looks like a kind of cell that's
wired with cameras the only thing we
know there sure kurt is guilty of at
this point is lying about matt and thus
obstructing an investigation plus he
must not be an idiot if he's been
getting away with killing for so long so
it seems likely that he'll make moves to
destroy any evidence after dexter got
that look inside the basement the arrest
feels like it might just be for lesser
charges and they won't be able to hold
him on those based on what we've seen
and what it says in the episode
description everything's pointing to a
big showdown between kurt and dexter all
of that being complicated by the fact
that harrison is more drawn towards kurt
right now than he is to his father if
they do find out he's the killer and
then they do lock him up it kind of
makes you wonder how the rest of the
season would play out there's also not
really any connective tissue here either
she was drawn to the caves because she
thought that kurt didn't want her to go
there but now that she's found iris can
she be sure that that's what kurt was
worried about and then beyond that how
would that connect him to all of her
other missing girl cases
i think the most likely thing is that
kurt did kill iris or if not that then
he played a role in hiding the body or
something iris being central to angela's
story and kurt being responsible for the
clue that brought her there there's not
a whole lot of room for natural feeling
twists because this happened a long time
ago and it seems like the other girls
went missing after i think there's a
really good chance that this is the
first person that kirk killed and
somehow the ritual we've seen from him
is him reliving what happened at that
time where it gets confusing is the
whole idea of the embalming the bodies
and what's going on there theory wise it
feels like after episode six that most
of the molly theories were actually
wrong or they were off plus the idea
that ed olson was audrey's real father
doesn't seem possible anymore either i
was wrong on that one i thought that was
pretty much a given but in the last
episode we found out that angela was
married to her biological father which
makes it seem like he was who he was and
he did actually die the other theory
there that seems to be put to rest was
that iris was her real mom and that we
would find out that she didn't just run
away like she thought but that she was
murdered if what audrey told harrison
was true that her birth mom was white
that her father was seneca and that he
was married to angela and they all lived
together as a family until he died well
that kind of makes it hard for ed to be
her dad and iris to be her mom doesn't
mean there won't be twists there but
that's what we got and for molly i do
think she's still gonna play a big part
in the ending but i don't think she came
to iron lake looking for dexter morgan
or following harrison she seems sincere
in saying that she came there because
she heard about matt going missing she
was hoping to get in on a story for the
podcast but i mean come on with both of
these characters they're there for a
reason her knowing so much about serial
killers and doing research on ones that
dexter is involved with that's going to
play a part in why she's there and the
same thing with ed olsen there has to be
a reason why they introduced that
character it's just that he hasn't shown
up for a few episodes now and most of
the things that made sense don't look
like they make so much sense anymore
it's funny how a lot of the stuff that's
going on right now is distracting
characters from what they were worried
about before discovering the dead body
of her high school friend who went
missing not only means that dexter's
background is useful for her it also
means she's not busy looking into his
story or thinking about how he came to
be there as jim lindsey after going to
new york and knowing that something's
going on with kurt mulley is also
pointed in his direction and even though
harrison is acting out violently dexter
is a little bit more concerned with who
he's hanging out with rather than what
he's doing so i said at the end of my
last video that after the last episode
it's obvious he has a violent streak at
the very least so what is going on with
him then and why did he bring the blade
when he went to visit audrey for the
second part the writer of episode 6 has
said in a couple of interviews that
harrison didn't go there with the
intention of harming her he likes her
he's into her and the razor was more
about him not wanting to leave it at
home since dexter goes through his
things and he still doesn't trust people
so when he said he carried it for
protection he wasn't actually lying from
the promotional photos we see that he
will be working the job that includes a
get up that makes him look like dear old
dad in a kill room and that he's not
going to get away with breaking the
other wrestler's arm scot-free we see in
this shot that his friends show up at
the truck stop looking for vengeance and
it looks like dexter might be lurking
around there too but if he intervenes in
a fight that might actually work against
him i'm not sure how that would go over
with a teenager having your dad step in
when you're in a fight and i mean
harrison did break that kid's arm with
very little provocation it wasn't a
normal response just like slashing ethan
with the straight razor wasn't a normal
response to listening to a podcast he
said that he thinks about hurting
everyone all the time and i don't think
he was being dramatic that doesn't mean
that he's like dexter although it does
probably mean that dexter will think he
is but there's something going on with
the kid and it's not that he's someone
else impersonating dexter's son
so he's kind of in a situation where he
can go either way is what i guess right
he can go full psycho or he can learn to
keep it at bay or the third option being
the dexter option i think that depending
on what happens in the next episode
we'll have a better idea of how the
ending is gonna play out we'll only have
three more episodes after that and it's
kind of hard to speculate since they
show kurt getting arrested in this
teaser how that plays out and where he's
at for the rest of the story is pretty
important in trying to figure out what's
gonna happen so i'll be curious to see
how the arrest plays out and how that
sets things up for dexter versus the
runaway killer even if kurt was able to
remove any evidence that might have been
there dexter knows what a room like that
means and he kind of made that clear to
kurt when he was poking around also
molly saw it and rightly thought that
she was about to be the next picture on
angela's carry from homeland board of
missing persons so even if he's not
arrested for being a killer or isn't
exposed for what's been going on at the
cabin there are a few people that know
also his son is dead and he lied about
talking to him while trying to make it
look like his credit cards were being
used in new york city and he's strangely
going out of his way to make friends
with harrison it's clear why dexter
doesn't like this but that doesn't
explain why he's doing it in the first
place in relation to that i've seen a
lot of theories about kurt being onto
dexter or at least suspecting that he
might have killed matt there's the
footage the close proximity of the crime
scene to his cabin and he did meet him
and sell him a gun right before it
happened that's all pretty thin the best
theory i read about dexter making a
mistake and killing matt was a comment
on my episode 3 video it brought up that
he might have had titanium rods or
screws put in his leg after the boat
accident and why that stood out is
because the camera kind of conspicuously
lingered on his scar when dexter went to
his room to deliver the gun if that is
what that was supposed to imply then the
rod or screw would be left behind in the
incinerator and those things have serial
numbers on them so it could be proof
that matt's body was disposed of there
or at least that he is actually dead i
think that that was a great catch i
think that's probably going to come into
play i just can't see how to tie it all
together with what's happening right now
in the story so i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about the last
episode what you think about this teaser
what you think is gonna happen next how
have your theories changed after episode
6 and whatever else is on your mind
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon